if a person comes to lamb to school and
they do not get a job
and they when they come in my
understanding is because i have
a close friend whose uh husband is in
the program right now would say who
you can either pay 20 000 or have
thousand dollars
in deferred isa am i ballpark correct
that's that's
roughly correct yep the person i know
paid the twenty thousand they had a
little bit of money they said yeah we
don't need to pay it over time we'll pay
the twenty thousand and we'll get a job
after whatever nine months of the
program
it's nine month program the people who
pay the 30 000 deferred with an income
sharing agreement
wind up paying forty or fifty thousand
dollars of their
back over time thirty thousand is the
max thirty thousands to max so the way
it works is you pay a
percentage of your income for two years
17 for two years
if and only if you're making more than
50k in a role that you trained for
if not you pay zero and thirty thousand
dollars is the maximum
so there will be students that pay
seventeen thousand dollars because they
only get a fifty thousand dollar your
job
right so you have to be making north of
eighty six
eighty seven k to pay thirty thousand
dollars
so what's interesting about this is
and i don't mean to just become like
your pr person
and your media counselor austin but if
it was me i would just come out dunking
like
you people are idiots there is no
downside you don't understand what an
isa
is you [ __ ] idiot reporters have no
idea
that there is zero downside to going to
lambda school
because if you don't get a job you are
not responsible and the debt wipes out
after how many years five years
okay so catherine just pause here for a
second and consider
the insanity of this
the person takes no risk
lambda takes 100 of the risk
if the person doesn't get a well-paying
job over 50k
they pay zero if they get a job outside
of tech
and develop being a developer they pay
zero well being a developer is
i mean you would pay if you're a
developer outside of tech right right if
you end up being a bartender for example
you're not paying then you don't pay a
waiter in the us
that's not true in the eu but in the us
right so you're not on the hook
and it wipes away after five years
catherine inc
for college you cannot even go bankrupt
and wipe out college debt correct
so austin you have created the giant
mitzvah of all mitzvahs for all of young
people who might want to transition
and the payback he gets is people don't
even understand
that nobody's on the hook how insane is
this
yeah no it's interest i mean austin and
i have had this conversation offline
before
but i was once in that boat when i
wanted to leave journalism i was you
know
not paid very well and was looking to
improve my life and ended up going to
business school
but that sort of solution of you don't
have to pay anything upfront actually
speaks to a huge sector of the american
public
that is terrified of taking on more debt
especially the people who've already
taken on debt
who went to university they believed the
american dream and said you can better
yourself with college
and then got out of college and were
paid 25 000
to do an entry-level job and really
can't afford to live in a city